there are 250 million cars trucks and
motorcycles packing America's streets
and an army of thieves looking to steal
them America's police are locked in a
game of cat and mouse
filled with car chases and hot pursuits
law enforcement is reaching out to
companies and their state-of-the-art
devices science computers and
leading-edge technology are transforming
the way police apprehend car thieves
[Music]
every year as many as 10,000 law
enforcement professionals come to learn
pursuit tech a pursuit is very dangerous
if you've ever been in one they're very
scary
high-resolution plasma screens in
advanced software create a complex
virtual environment that demands an
officer's full concentration while
inside the simulator an officer must
simultaneously manage a fully functional
dashboard the gear selector works the
headlights work and the police emergency
equipment works sirens side lights side
alley lights and overheads to best
simulate the environment for the officer
while some technologies make it easier
to catch car thieves too many devices
can complicate matters for an officer
trying to apprehend a suspect as a
former police officer I've had to use a
steering wheel with one hand talked on
the radio with another work a computer
hit different buzzards flip switches for
my siren turn my radio on and off and
still be in control of my vehicle so
police departments across the u.s. are
turning to a new consolidating
technology to rid their cars of clutter
a system called tack net alert three
[Music]
tack net short for tactical network
shifts a multitude of separate systems
from the dashboard to the trunk
including the controls for lights and
sirens the scanner radios radar video
and computer system technologies that
allow a police officer to focus on the
road can help bring a dangerous
encounter to a safe and
that's definitely true of another
technology there's a hunter in the sky
above unhindered by the dark a hunter
with infrared eyes
the Columbus Ohio Police Department has
a small fleet of helicopters armed with
a system called FLIR forward-looking
infrared infrared is not in the visible
part of the spectrum but what's
invisible to human eyes is clear as day
- Flair's camera calibrated to precisely
detect the infrared section of
electromagnetic spectrum the camera
displays a video image to the
helicopters copilot the more infrared
radiation and object gives off the
brighter it appears and unfortunately
for car thieves their bodies are
infrared emitting machines spewing
radiation in the form of body heat with
1.2 million cars stolen each year
auto theft is a nationwide problem this
car has some pretty neat bells and
whistles on it what we've got here our
license plate reader cameras the license
plate recognition technology or LPR
literally takes a picture of every plate
it encounters and can determine if the
vehicles been stolen in a fraction of a
second a huge advancement over the old
method
get all those beeps it's picking up
plates on either side of us right here
cars coming towards us cars they're
parked on the side of the road
it all starts the instant of car passes
one of the LPRs cameras like this
minivan two pictures are taken a color
picture for visual identification and an
infrared picture that infrared image
travels to the computer located in the
trunk a series of sophisticated software
programs first identifies the position
of the plate on the image extracts it
and breaks the plate into individual
characters number and letter recognition
programs determine what each character
is the plate number is then compared
against a database of more than 300,000
vehicles of interest and if a vehicle's
plate matches oh there we go we got a
stone right there